hey everyone hey and welcome to the
first episode of watching The Watchmen
this is your co-host tom cui i joined by
definition of course deaf had to go man
yeah really good man really excited to
get into this watchman's probably one of
my favorite comic book series of all
time and DC I do not at the moment where
they're bringing it back I think the
film's really underrated hello
underrated hate you Don unfairly I think
yeah definitely you know and I'm just
really excited to kind of jump back into
this and see exactly where the source
material it what if it still holds up I
mean I've got really fond memories of it
and I'm just kind of interested to
reread it and see if it's still as good
as I remember yeah yeah completely I
mean you know it's mad really like with
Watchmen that there isn't a podcast
series going for each issue like I would
have thought this would have been the
first one that people would have done
out there you know obviously podcasting
lends itself so well to this episodic
analysis but here we are you know we're
going to go through all 12 issues you
know episode by episode here and sort of
you know going through chronicling the
story and our thoughts and our
interpretations the whole thing
obviously Watchmen is you know monolith
it's a genius genius piece of work
really really excited to get into this
and to go through it and I mean I guess
I guess first of all we should maybe say
how we know each other if people listen
to this maybe less of a battle rap mind
I myself am a podcaster I do a few
podcasts including one called batter up
resume or I speak to battle rappers if
the words king of the dark don't fall
off or your mom mean anything to you
then you might be aware of battle
rapping some form and add effing you're
a battle rapper or I guess in a certain
you know kind of watchman sense you're
like a sort of retired hero yeah sort of
the have died off a bit the new bloods
in at the moment and so I'm just trying
to stay relevant by doing as much thing
there's many little commentaries as I
can so yeah that's been advising that
I'm sort of looking to go into more
review and comics I've got a website at
definition code
UK we're currently reading through all
the Batman graphic novels review the
flash Suicide Squad x-men that sort of
thing so this is just kind of an
extension of that and it's a good merry
enough of the two Tom you obviously do
your your podcast and I'm sort of doing
my comic book review so it's it's a good
like middle ground between the whole
thing yeah yeah exactly and I agree
something like we've Watchmen especially
I think it deserves this sort of in
depth treatment and it's going to be
really fun actually because obviously
we've done quite a few podcasts together
pretty much exclusively about battle rap
so this is a completely new dimension
for us and before we get into the you
know the first issue what was your
history watchman how did you become
aware of the novel I'd always thought of
heard of it and the smiley face with the
blood splatter on it some kind of like
one of the outstanding images and comic
books like if you google comic books I'm
sure that'll be somewhere on there and
it just sort of seeped into the public
consciousness and then I remember the
movie coming out and it was so I think
was the 2008 which was the same year as
the Dark Knight
I'm sure got released in the February of
that year I think I think it was that it
was the oh nine I think yeah it was like
around the March on I think that yeh was
very very kind of of that era
yeah and basically that just I watched
that and it got a lot of criticism and I
couldn't really see it myself and people
were saying my other the graphic novels
better and this is just sort of about
the time that I was really getting back
into comic groups so I thought I'll go
I'll go check out the graphic novel
because everyone's saying so much better
than than the film which I really
enjoyed and yeah that's kind of how I
got into it and then obviously Alan
Moore I'm quite a big fan of in all the
controversy that surrounds him with it
with this novel especially it just got
me really interested in that mmm immerse
myself into it more and more yeah yeah I
remember this is like probably about the
tenth year that I've been reading
Watchmen I remember got Watchmen on
holiday when I was on holiday with my
parents when I was like
I was 16 years old and we were in a in
America and I remember going to some
Barnes & Noble or some [ __ ] like that
and and they had this display of like
you know the great the great graphic
novels and I was just getting into
graphic novels and like you I was aware
of Watchmen I knew it was like this
iconic thing but I had no idea what the
story was you know I'd have any clue and
I remember reading it and I remember
quite enjoying it but not quite getting
it all like like yeah bits of it went
over my head and I was a bit confused of
it and stuff like that and I sort of put
it to one side and then about a year
later about a year or so like that the
film was coming out I remember the
trailer came out and I was like oh yeah
I own this and I went back and I read it
a bit more carefully and I was just you
know blown away obviously again in July
just 40 was incredible always the
matheletes and I still think it's a
masterpiece and I you know still sort of
go back and revisit I remember going to
see the film after school going on my
own on the day it came out and like you
know I was very very excited and not
disappointed at all I guess just before
we get into the first issue of just this
is verbatim from Wikipedia
I thought this is very useful as a bit
of background so this is from the
Wikipedia article just just a bit of
background information on the on the
novel itself so Watchmen is an American
comic book limited series published by
DC in 1986 and 1987 the series is a
collaboration between Alan Moore Dave
Gibbons and John Higgins or all British
which which doesn't really bother it's
got a nice we originated from a story
proposal more submit DC featuring
superior characters but the company
acquired from Charlton comics and
Charlton are actually referenced in in
the series but we'll get to that we'll
sort of build out the history more but
just in a general span more proposed
story would have left many of the
characters unusable for future stories
so managing editor dick Giordano
convinced more to create original
character instead more use Watchmen as a
means to reflect contemporary anxieties
and to deconstruct and parodied a
superhero concept it depicts an
alternative history where super is
emerged in the 40s and 60s and their
presence changed history to the u.s. one
the Vietnam War and the Watergate
scandal was never exposed in 85 where of
the main action is set the country is
edging towards World War 3 with the
Soviet Union
freelance costume vigilante has been
outlawed in most form of superheroes in
retirement or working for the government
the story focus on the personal
development and mole struggles of the
protagonist and
investigation into the murder of a
government-sponsored superoes pulls them
out of retirement and then finally just
in kind of summary of its release
a commercial success watchman has
received critical acclaim both in the
comics and mainstream press and is
considered by several critics reviewers
- one of the most significant works of
20th century literature watchman is
recognizing Times list of 100 best
novels as one of the best
english-language novels Publishing's
1923 and it was placed number 91 on the
comic journals list of the top 100 comic
books of the 20th century the BBC
described as the moment comic grew the
component comic books grew up with yeah
which i think is fair really and it you
know when you read that that it's in the
top 100 best novels you know of the last
200 years I mean you know I studied
English literature you know I am a big
fan of you know kind of serious
literature and stuff like that you fill
across shakespeare's you Chaucer's
whatever what Sherman stands toe-to-toe
with that is so sophisticated is amazing
yeah it's just absolutely brilliant I
mean this is kind of it came out the
time when comics were really growing up
as well like The Dark Knight Returns got
released the same year and there was
this whole sort of basically this
construction of exactly what comics were
like they've been around for so long and
it was getting to a point where it was
the same idea rehashed over and over and
instead of doing that a same thing again
Alan wah Frank Miller and Neil Gaiman
that crowd
they decided to really get into what the
characters were actually like on a
psychological level and how they existed
in the real world if they could exist in
the real world if they did exist in the
real world what sort of things would
would be their problems like you've got
the president in this you've got the
Cold War I mean it is interesting how to
think how exactly would a superhero
tackle something like the Cold War and
that's for with espionage and this
really doesn't exactly you know how that
would would probably go down yeah yeah
and I mean we're getting to the issue in
a second but I think the strength of it
not only lies in that the kind of the
ideas of the real thing the characters
are absolutely fantastic
I think they just sketched brilliantly
the profile the genius the art by Dave
Gibbons is exceptional and it's such a
clever comic just in the sort of you
know the world so stuffed with
references like the meltdowns and and
pale horse and the smiley badge and
there's just you know I think I think I
read comic Dave Gibbons was saying like
it almost has like a crystalline
structure like how when you look inside
a crystal everything reflects each other
and it definitely has that you know that
element to it that that spirit but we'll
get to the first issue and I don't know
about you death but one of the things
that I love about Watchmen is the cover
image is always the blood for another
yeah I've got that in mine oh yeah it's
brilliant like I've never really seen
anything like that before or since we're
that's your first panel so you instantly
right into the the comic book itself
like I don't know if you've seen comic
book covers from the aeo 70s in the 60s
but they're all kind of they've got like
speech bubbles on the middle kind of the
hero on the front with a speech bubble
coming out explaining exactly what
happens in the comic yeah and this is
just good sleight a work of art on the
front
it really is yeah I mean you think of
like the old Avengers covers and stuff
and be like you know whole Canfor kind
of approaching and it's like not is it
you know and if one will die this issue
and this is just seamless really going
straight into it there's actually a I
don't know if you be aware this guy I
gave this to someone I just go through
my literature readings as a student this
guy called um it's hallow Calvino's
kinase very influential in Italian
writer and he did something similar
where the front cover of his book has
the first paragraph on the actual curve
and it goes it's kind of there's no
artifice there and with this as well and
let's talk about this cover as well so
we have the comedian's badge in the
gutter the blood flowing it's very
effective yeah definitely it's got a
really nice composition to it and the
colors are really striking the yellow
against the red and just it's quite a
striking image it's not given away the
whole yeah of exactly what's going on
which sort of sums of the images so the
issue itself
where it begins with an investigation
and then it kind of goes from there and
you sort of think are that the whole
story is going to be about um Rorschach
they could be stopping this superhero
and serial killer and there's so much
more depth to it
I think it's summed up perfectly just
with this cover you know like a
one-point Rorschach references how
everyone's in the gutter yeah and just
to start off in the gutter a smiley face
of basically the smile is like
blissfully ignorant and that kind of
some so exactly what happens throughout
the storyline like is it better to be
ignorant to give too much away now for
the basically the summation of the story
is is it better to be ignorant than to
know the true horrors of everything
that's going on and that sort of is
summed up almost in this opening image
of just like a smile and face line in
the gutter of blood yeah yeah yeah
completely and again again the image I
don't know even thought of it on that
level no I know we really do start
thinking about you know Oklo get more at
this really well planned out yeah oh no
no no like I think I think Watchmen is
you know it is about close reading there
is so much in these panels and I think
the image is so strong as well because
obviously the image is taking the idea
of the superhero and making it gritty
which at this time was very original and
if you think about that it's blood on a
smiley face it's kind of violence on the
comic and it's kind of it's the epitome
of Watchmen as a whole and I love love
the first panel I mean disregarding sort
of Rorschach's journal as a whole for a
second I love how the whole panel it's
still focused on that smiley face but
we're just going higher and higher and
higher so you're sort of a very shape in
the world around it and if you look on
the fifth panel you can I believe you
can still see like a little circle on
the grid you can still almost like
squint it out the perspective of it as
we come on and like you know throughout
the entirety of Watchmen there is this
idea of irony you know so he says in the
first panels the city is afraid of me
I've seen it
true faith and they know folks yeah the
face there and then he talks about you
know the the you know the waste and all
the quality and the gutter the
accumulate bill obviously you say the
gutter shot and I love in the fourth
panel when he says they had a choice all
of them and they could have followed in
the footsteps of good men and you see
his footsteps coming out the blood yeah
absolutely brilliant just so well put
together I did read something that Helen
Morel use the rope but every single
panel there is used to write a page
didn't describing exactly what was going
on in a panel and then you always used
to end it with or whatever you think's
best Davis we can do that for every
single page so for every panel in this
has been obsessed over and it's very
rare that you pass through something
that doesn't have a subtext to it oh
yeah yeah completely and one of the
books that I got and I'm sure people
beware I was watching The Watchmen by
Dave Gibbons we just kind of like all
his sketches and stuff like that it's
absolutely brilliant and he shows in the
book some of the things Alan Moore sent
him and you're right yet it's like every
panel is kind of spell out so expecially
and one of the little things that I love
as well as you see in the third and the
fourth panels the van going by that has
Adrienne symbol on it the pyramid yeah
so it's going in the opposite direction
to Russia as well that's right oh yeah
of course it is yeah yeah which sort of
also you know gives away the ending of
the book in their ideology sewing it so
you know the fact we're talking about
this just first page very few comic
books that you could do this about and I
haven't even talked about the press
speech paneling yet which is sort of the
name that's given to the layout of it
right yes there's no real splash pages
everything is in this nine panel grid
and that kind of is the constraints of
the comic and but they've given just a
such a good job with using every single
panel to it's like basically so it's
bursting full with just so many hidden
things yeah yeah yeah no it really is a
joy to pick over and I love as well I
mean this is like less of a kind of
clever thing by just like it
in the top corner of the second panel
you sort of see the books coming out
from the side and then yeah when you get
into the sort of next panel you see kind
of the one obviously we've read this
many times so we know that this is
Walter Kovacs this is yeah with the end
is nigh thing and one of the things
death but I'm always interested by know
we think about it doesn't quite make
sense when you when you meet Rorschach
in the comic
he's quite laconic he's quite brisk but
his journal is quite beautifully written
yeah it's very strange but I don't want
to like jump too far ahead but when
Rorschach talks and his speech bubbles
are yeah very like shaky and the like
squiggly lines pretty much and there's
actually a point in the comic where we
have a flashback to Rorschach and before
this trauma happened and and before that
his speech is absolutely fine so it
almost sort of symbolizes how he became
broken as a man and just the characters
been so well thought out yeah just from
the start
I mean he's hiding in plain sight and he
delivering the message that the end is
nigh and that's sort of the position
that he takes within the buki thinks the
world's coming to an end and
everything's going to come crumbling
down and he's the only one who can stop
it really
mmm-hmm and again we have the irony of
the journal so on this sort of six panel
you know all of a sudden nobody can
think of anything to say and then we get
offer a sense of speech which is the
detective you know yeah looking down a
lot I just I'm really in awe of how
clever is how it goes from the gutter
all the way up to the sky rise and we're
smasheroo I love that we go so high up
we can see the bald spot on the detect
year header and that that's like you
know before this comic books everyone
was sort of paid to be there if it if
you think of the the sixties man which
is like a man with it he's pumping his
chest out he's got his hands at his side
it's sucking his stomach in that was
like what pretty much everyone in comic
books look like before this point and
then this is just like the normality of
it
old perch is just you know he's not
shocked by any of this before before I
like this comic if someone had a falling
out a window there would have been like
wow zip we got to get to the bottom of
this yeah the policeman sort of just
like the opening features just hmm
yeah which is kind of you know it really
sums up just the the mood of the entire
comic everyone's so over exposed to
violence and they're just used to it
really yeah yeah yeah no completely and
again from its angle you kind of have
that you know recap of what you can see
Rorschach of is sine moving on you can
see Adrienne's van you can see the blood
you can just appreciate and I think I
think it's return to quite a bit this of
intersection in New York we see it from
sort of multiple angles and and of
course as well as we're saying
Rorschach's journal is really
interesting as well you know the
accumulated filth of all their sex and
murder will foam up around their waist
and all the pores and politicians will
look up and shout save us and all we all
look down and whisper no it's just it
just very you know really really
powerful and it's brutal like you don't
expect a superhero refugee if someone
says save us
you don't expect a superhero or just say
no back and that's just this sums up the
entire mood of the comic within this
first page either Watchmen are heroes
but they're not you could e to shoot
heroes they're not yet there Blue Boy
Scout who not jump out to save anyone
with it it's all sort of a choice that
Rorschach makes whether people are worth
saving or not or if they're all just
doomed like like he thinks they are
basically yeah yeah I mean I mean again
I don't want to jump head too much but I
agree like I remember reading it for the
first time and at the start the second
issue when the comedian you know
brutally attacks Sally and tries to rape
her like in the head course like bloody
hell like you know it is it is just like
by the knuckle and then then we get to
the second and third pages which is kind
of the detectives exploring comedians
apartment which which I really like as
well the sort of idea that they you know
believe it was to be two men and it can
toast
SCOTUS at and the use of the flashbacks
are fantastic as well going back into
the red and just you know you almost
Amish when you read this a second time
you appreciate even more because
comedian is a real kind of trigger but
here is make it look a pricing yeah it's
just come get his ass kicked basically
oh yeah um and it just is so brutal like
to see someone get murdered in this
fashion with getting beaten up and then
thrown out of a window and if you would
never really see a supervillain do that
but before this I mean a supervillains
plan was always steal a bomb or get a
laser and say if you don't pay me a
million dollars I'm going to destroy the
the White House or something they never
just showed up in the middle of the
night kick the door open beat someone up
and then threw them out of the window
and there was always kind of a motive to
it for for money and this just seems
like it's a brutal murder and which
really wasn't commonplace at the time no
no not at all and again you know we're
going to go for it all this series going
to be us you know fascinated by these
panels and the touches are they put in
but I love comedians apartments you
actually see a set of golf clubs in the
corner which I can't imagine comedian
ever using but yeah you know there you
go and obviously there's like booze and
you see you see a pirate ship as well or
like a sort of I'm going to the pirate
ship you're not going to old school ship
with the big sales in the end result is
a nice kind of in reference and lovely
as well that we see on the third page
you know how the blood got on the badge
kind of it dripping from his face at all
yeah yes absolutely horrendous thing the
guy just like this is the one Ruby had
it in for this guy yes once you see what
the comedian does Raghu you can sort of
understand why someone would be this
brutal towards them mm-hmm definitely
and him just you know getting kind of
picked up and thrown out and you know
again throughout this book we're going
to see it the descent of dramatic irony
and I love which floor do you want
ground floor please ground floor coming
up and then we have the comedian being
smashed out the window yeah absolutely
brilliant and then the next
one is sort of as the next page as the
policemen go down in the list yes also
shows the comedian going down on the
outside of the building yeah and it's
just odd it's brilliant gift so shocking
when you really deconstruct it and the
policeman even walk past Rorschach yes
and you know they get a shiver just from
the atmosphere that it gives off but he
saw hiding in plain sight Rorschach
I think he's adopted this homeless
persona because you can move almost
invisible like people won't look at you
they don't want to make eye contact and
that's why the doctored this he's hiding
in plain sight directly in front of
people investigating the crimes and he's
just able to do this because you
sacrificed his own life for his most in
dedication to this cause yeah and again
on this on this page as well this would
be the fourth page you know we I just
it's horrific scene the comedian splayed
out as he falls downwards as well yeah I
don't know whether it's an issue issue
or one of them but Rorschach says like
he fell in his head and his head went
into his stomach yeah you know the
visual image is terrific and again there
were loads of these pointy details so
when the policemen come out you see a
guy I don't know if it's the main kid
who reads the black freighter but
there's someone reading the black
freighter and you can see on the
newspaper as well it says Vietnam 51st
state as well so it's there's just those
little things in this world which I mean
we kind of appreciate a bit more now
reading it in 2017 you know I'm going to
be a bit more aware but at the time it's
just little hints by more and deben to
say this world is like our world but you
know there's tiny differences that
amount to quite a bit yeah definitely it
sort of the butterfly effect yeah and
we're tiny little things have had a
massive knock-on effect to how the world
exists around them even the cars and
stuff you can give us be futuristic
which is obviously because dr. Manhattan
yeah he existed so the the years been
able to sort of gain inspiration from
him and designing use his power to
advance technology even further and it's
such sort of team yeah and almost yeah
yeah I remember the first time I mean
it's a much later issue but when they
have Hollis Mason and when you meet dr.
Manhattan at that fundraiser or whatever
and you know they're talking about
electric cars and then hands just say oh
I can sympathize this certain thing now
so yeah they are necessary and then it
mentions that Kennedy was shot in an
electric car on Dealey Plaza which is
just where all right you know amazing
amazing we also see the Ganga diner here
for the first time which which Laurie
and Dan will go into and and Rorschach
as well we see that says all the little
futuristic there's a guy wearing like a
sort of gold visor just in the corner
where annals you know lots of lot of
stuff here and I love the description of
Rorschach he's crazier than the snakes
armpit yeah and it's also in this page
that they talk about the Keene act and
yes which it basically says that only
government-sponsored superheroes are
active and all vigilantism has been
outlawed and obviously some people have
ignored that call like Rorschach and but
the fact that you think oh well how bad
must this will be that superheroes who
were meant to help people have even been
classed as outlaws like you would never
see this before the police always went
to Batman for help I mean had a fat
signal so they could call him directly
and you would never ever see the
government pass something where they
know if you're a superhero here you're a
criminal basically yeah ya know
completely and we get of the sort of you
know interaction with a quote on quote
here or here in on the fifth page which
I really like it's completely wordless
compared to all the ones before which
have had so much information you know
going back and forth alternate history
sort of thing but you know here we have
Rorschach and I like the way the
introducing because you sort of see a
shadow and his hats yeah and it and it's
very classic but then when he goes to
reach his grappling gun you realize that
he's like is shirts very ratty and dirty
yeah it's very subtle as well you would
never know
pick up on its own Yin following
read-throughs that you would ever see
that and but it's like so well done mmm
and his designs based on the question
yam which one of the characters that DC
bought from Charlton comics he is very
similar looks wise I mean if you google
the question usually it's pretty much
the same character except for Rorschach
has a Rorschach test for a mask and and
just what I love about Rorschach's mask
is that it's just black and white yeah
which sums up his ideology you know
there's no shades of gray now everything
was black and white to him and and you
see into this mask of black and white
yeah yeah yeah it's big yeah he's
beautiful like yeah this or the the
symbolism and the way to voted one of
the things I always wondered about this
bit in the books I always thought like
if the detectives were searching the
case and downstairs don't you think they
would have seen the smiley face I don't
know how they would have missed it I
think it's because I guy was just
washing away the blood like right they
just viewed it as a just another death
in the city and then yeah we'll just get
wash it away we're never going to solve
this I mean the policemen don't make any
real no effort to try and solve the case
they just see it as another burglary and
yeah yeah no yeah it's just I think
that's the whole attitude to that in the
society where it's like bad things
happen but you just get on with it and
forget about it
which Rorschach sort of throughout the
book he opposes that he doesn't want to
forget about things he wants to
acknowledge how horrifying everything is
mm-hmm
and a common theme throughout this issue
especially is when we are introduced to
the characters there's this sense of
height or the sense of like them being
above or below we definitely see it we
doctor on hand we see when we get to
night hour and a bit as well and here
we're all chat we have the same thing I
just love I love the way it works at the
motion was his gun comes out he shoots
the grappling hook we just fires like
really tall and like gives you the sense
of him below the thing and then him
scaling the wall and you're sort of
learning here that
wish I didn't necessarily a superhero
he's relying on instruments but still
what he's doing is pretty super yeah
definitely I mean he does have a lot of
similarities to Batman I've always kind
of viewed Rorschach as how Batman
actually is night-owls how Batman thinks
that he is yeah like Rorschach he
doesn't have a life is the mask is his
real face hmm whereas Nite Owl sort of
he thinks that he's normally thinks he
can walk away anytime and exist without
the crime-fighting life but I mean he
can't really so Batman thinks that in
his head or I'm only here for a while
whilst Gotham City needs me but if
Gotham City was fine he would still find
a reason go out and I invite criminals
and Rorschach's or is that yeah I'm
completely yeah I think we see in a
light ratio again and so going up when
the Keene Act is is invoked he he got
drops off like a rapist bodied as other
police as means as like I'm never going
to retire or something like that which
is which is really powerful and then yet
again pretty wordless here I love the
shot of him just hanging you know
getting into the building and you see
the city behind him and you know it
again you sort of appreciate he's not
but he's got this kind of coat and hat
on but when you see he's kind of got
these sort of happy trails as well and
he's belts kind of loose on him and you
know he isn't necessarily that good and
I love this whole sequence really him
exploring getting to the cupboard
opening it it's great yeah it just shows
like how thorough that he is the fact
that the police missed this he knows
something's strange about this and he
goes through it top to bottom till you
find something whereas the police are
happy to just walk in look at the window
look over the edge and go yeah that's it
so it really shows how much above the
police that the superheroes are yeah and
obviously the policeman it's just a job
to them and they can clock in they can
clock out where is Rorschach business's
entire life and he doesn't want to leave
any stone unturned so he's happy to go
work overtime work in the middle of the
night and code through thoroughly or
as the police just seem and not care and
I think a lot of the circumstances that
happen and throughout this book are
because society is just nonchalant
towards young out standing up for
themselves and really taking control
mm-hmm and you know he get the opens of
the cupboard finds I mean it's quite
interesting because throughout the
series you see the comedian in quite a
number of costumes that sort of evolved
and this is obviously is kind of its
latest costume the one he's kind of
doing the more knocking down the Marxist
Republic's the government work but I
love seeing this hangs costume it's
quite creepy isn't it like not only is
there the knife and the gun is like
[ __ ] out but it's like the mask
itself that's what haunting yeah and if
you don't know like the sleeves
they're very clearly referencing the
American flag and you've got so the
chameleon sort of softness of everything
that America is that it's smiling he's
happy but you absolutely psychopath in
your murder you oh yeah without a
moment's notice yeah yeah completely and
I mean rush I just unpacked things and
then obviously spots the the minutemen
picture of the old Subarus and this is
the what I mean what obviously we're
going to explore all these kind of
histories and stuff but this is one of
the things that I absolutely love about
Watchmen I love how there were two
groups of superheroes one that inform
the other they kind of sum up different
eras and how it goes between the past
and the present to explore kind of what
they were yes absolutely brilliantly
done it's sort of like on the next page
we'll see that it the photograph ties
into the original night owl yeah and it
shows him as a retired man it shows like
yeah when you're younger you think being
a superhero is great it's full of
adventures but beyond that once you grow
old as there's nothing really there for
you hmm
and it just kind of it's almost tragic
to see him standing there like smiling
in this costume
and then it's just it pulls out and
you've got a tiny little yeah
apartment and graffiti like that the
place is really rundown and for a guy
who gave so much to to now be in this
position it sort of sums up to me like
soldiers McGough to war they fight the
war everyone cheers them on and then
when they come back there's not much
there for them I don't get you working
alike veteran homeless and right right
it's so to me sums of that yet you see
these people as heroes and then they
come back the lights just no one really
Q wants to support them beyond their
better adventures really yeah yeah yeah
completely and I agree yes all because
so much of this is kind of messing with
the iconography of superheroes but this
picture of night owl especially he's the
all-american hero his knees got sore the
the visor on he's got the broad you know
powerful TV smiles or thing and you know
that Watchmen for out is all about
transitions how we get from scene to
scene and I love that I say Watchmen so
I think Rorschach is looking at this
photo of the Minutemen and then we
transition to you know another version
is photo which is in Hollis Mason's kind
of abode here this scene always reminds
me of like The Incredibles when like
Frozone and mr. incredible are like
reminiscing on like old years and stuff
like I love it
definitely and before this point like
superheroes were immoral you would never
see you just thought our Superman he's a
man in his 30s and it doesn't matter
what decade you're in you just say yes
Superman's always going to stay thirty
forever there's a matter of 15 you you
reading a comic in the 1940s have you
eaten it in the 1970s you always saw
this timeless bigger that never ages and
then to see a man who used to be a
superhero he's now old worn out it was
it's quite John and I can imagine at the
time that really shook things up like to
take these characters out of this
immortality that they had within the
pages and then prompt them in modern day
where they're sitting at the table smoke
and lightnin fire on a Friday night it
it's really like jarring to think about
it yeah completely in you know so many
details here to pick over helpfully
Hollis Mason framed a newspaper article
that help let us know that he's retired
he's opened up his own auto business one
of the things that I saw death that just
slipped me by and I caught it on this
route you see like his dog he's like
wolf dog at his feet yeah um kind of I
mean I don't want to compare it to
Bubastis but kind of the dog looks like
not very doglike you know what I mean it
looks quite like a like a bit stronger
than that yeah definitely oh yeah that's
the first time I've ever noticed it as
well um yeah they know exactly how that
ties in no oh actually well I've just
discovered this live on air but I just I
just skipped ahead because obviously
Hollis Mason spoiler is killed and when
he's killed those flashbacks between him
fighting crime and him being beaten and
then the flashbacks you see the dog you
know like Superman had his dog and stuff
like yes
so make maybe what the dog is retired as
well yeah I mean everyone's growing old
in this world if it's a shaggy old dog
really so yeah you know it's um it's
good and then obviously we have you know
Hollis and Dan that at this point we
don't really well we could just say you
were a better Nite Owl and I never was
so it kind of gives you that link
between but I love the fourth panel when
they're getting up and you sort of see
the the statue of gratitude to him from
the past and there's under the hood
which we'll get to this autobiography
that he wrote about early days and
there's another book here you just see
it briefly gladiator and this quick bit
of Ricka Pete Wikipedia this is
apparently one of the influences on
Superman this is a run a real book this
was published in 1930 by Philip Wylie
this is from Wikipedia American science
fiction novel the story concerns a
scientist who invents an alkaline free
serum to improve humankind by granting
the proportionate strength of an ant and
the leaping ability of the grasshopper
the scientist injects his pregnant wife
with the serum and his son Hugo Danner
is born with superhuman strength speed
and bulletproof skin and yet apparently
there's no confirmation that it was the
influence of Superman but most people
you know yeah and he had a big s on his
chest no II do know that but um you know
regards but you know I love this I love
this sense of the time changing and you
know when Dan leaves you realized that
you know Hollis hasn't retired to his
Batcave he lives in a bit of a shitty
area yeah this isn't a horrible area
he did not billionaires and it's really
depressing to see where he's been
resigned to live now and it's just
horrible for the guy sort of sacrifice
his life to help so many people and this
is the thanks that yes lemon statue in a
little apartment above a repair shop
yeah yeah yeah and we see as well when
he leaves who watches the Watchmen we
see all the graffiti which which
apparently I read this online you never
see the full thing you always really a
bit of it cover so you can kind of put
two and two together II in mind and
stuff like that and then again this use
of irony I love the fact that both of
these old heroes leave and we see this
shot of the you know it's verily
obsolete models yes that's pretty of
them it's so well done yeah just sums up
the entire conversation between the two
just past it now they're they're no
longer relevant and this is that
obsolete yeah yeah yeah no it no really
really is brilliant and we see also like
a box for the Ganga diner we see you
know a poster for pale horse who are
these band and obviously pale horse as
well as a reference to like the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse and the idea
of sort of in penny and you'll notice as
well the clock on the mantelpiece is
like two minutes to midnight right okay
all we countdown the doomsday exactly
exactly so you know all of this stuff is
packed in there and then we get to the
next page where we sort of see you know
Dan returning home we you get an
appreciation for his wealth as opposed
to the old night out because like the
sign says like floors one two for
dreiberg so he has some sort of
warehouse thing and you know notices of
the doors locked
I've seen some readings of this if you
see the panel where the fifth panel
where he sort of silhouette in the
doorway some people say he looks like an
owl there which I can kind of see yeah
so them I think it's good oh it's got
the nostalgia he walks past that yeah
yeah which is just what he's just came
from it's just so I've been having a
nostalgic talk with the original night
owl
just look so sir let's organ down that
memory memory lane almost yeah and it's
just I can sort of see the owl in it
yeah yeah it's not it's not too too
blatant there and you also walked past
Treasure Island which is here which is a
reference to the fact that which i think
is genius by Dave and Alan the idea that
if superheroes did exist no one would
read to hero comics
so therefore parrot comics became their
commerce just and you can sort of see in
the window you can see a boat you can
see a treasure chest and all that sorted
so I guess like that's their Forbidden
Planet
you know Treasure Island is something
and then you know we get to office of us
meeting you know of the characters and
again I love the raggedy of speech marks
that he has and the first time we meet
Rorschach he's you know he's not this
eloquent beautiful man with big he's
eaten cold beans yeah
just stuff in his face just opened its
that open it kind of being just sitting
there on someone's table splashing
everywhere and it clearly doesn't care
about his die or what people think of
him yeah just really yeah yeah it is
brilliant and you know we we know these
guys have sort of been really comes here
all check is coming here to warn Dan you
know he feels uh some sort of thing
going on and you sort of get Dan's
slightly aloof humor where he frozen the
bean heroes in the badge and he's like
is that a stain or is that bean juice
yeah and you just get the feeling that
Dan's really upset that that Rorschach
even there I mean it went from one place
where he's been talking with an ex super
hero and he's been totally comfortable
with that and you know he was clearly
he's clearly very fond of Hollis Mason
and he walks along the street and then
bumps into another super hero and he's
almost horrified of exactly what's going
on it's strange how he's got this sort
of nostalgic feeling towards and being
night out but then when he's confronted
with some money he uses like a lost
cause he just doesn't want anything to
do with them hmm and I love that
Rorschach
without the sugar as well and pockets
loads of those and then I think I think
it's in the next issue or one of them
when Laurie comes back in the offers a
sugar and obviously is missing and it
just you know it's really really nice
there I should say as well another thing
just quickly on the special first panel
of the previous page when went down to
will be back you see the newspapers were
a Russia protest us advance in
Afghanistan yeah so to build out this
kind of you know this very very tense
world and I don't think not in the
seventh panel the whole whole sort of
them interacting is being quite close
and then we have like almost an outdoor
looking in from the window yeah I quite
like that as they open up into the cave
the the panels get larger yeah and it's
just like it's sort of opening up the
actual world you've been looking at them
through this keyhole and now they open
the door and that they're showing you
what they're really like mm-hm and we go
down into the the night that the owl
cave I suppose yeah you can sort of
really as and you can tell you know
things are dripping the paint cans its
you haven't been sort of seen to in a
while and I mean I love this whole
sequence I love their interaction and
then because like it built it out as
well we're dancing oh it might have been
a burglary and he's saying like an
ordinary burglar kill the comedian
ridicu and and then we see Rorschach's
face change like what how does that work
what are we just supposed to sort of
just accept I love it don't get me wrong
but it's quite interesting is it that
his spots gonna change how he's feeling
yeah it sort of signifies exactly what
he's thinking I don't know exactly how
you meant to read in Adam but there are
certain signifiers that when things
appear on his face he's feeling a
certain way or he's thinking about
something and they when the further
apart I think it meant to be sort of
opened things yet when they're closed up
and jammed together it sort of angry
mm-hmm yeah that might not be true I
don't know know sometimes sometimes you
can see him like surprised you actually
see it when he when he gets the
comedian's cupboard open earlier you see
the kind of far far apart I almost like
exclamation marks sort of things so yeah
really it is it is really really
interesting and you know a wreck
again the book that Hollis row which
which we get to at the end of the thing
that we've seen earlier and you know and
we also learned that they used to be
partners as well and for me it's the
powerful bit of this is the final three
panels when he says you quit and he
walks down but the perspective is
exactly the same we just further down so
yeah this sense that like he's literally
just he's walked away dan has stood
still and just sort of reflected on kind
of you know all that's changed yeah
exactly well that sort of some sort of
like Dan was willing to stop doing it
and stop Mary was whereas Rorschach just
kept going and Dan sort of sad that has
happened almost he's looking at the
badge you slumped over and you can tell
the guys not happy whereas Rorschach
just wanting to keep going never
stopping mmm-hmm and we see the you know
first look at the night out costume
which which I guess I think it's called
as most there's a lot of Batman a lot of
these characters really but I think
night owl is kind of the most obvious
thing and like I like the name as well
but it's quite a goofy name when you
think about it really like he is a night
owl bravia does the pun on sort of
people stay up late there are no elves
or that yeah it's just another like
witty you know element to the book I
think Dave Gibbons actually invented
night I was a kid and we carried this
superhero around for ages and this was
like the perfect project to just bring
his own character to the forefront with
yeah and I mean brilliant interaction as
well kind of you know sets up a lot of
what's that people would great to see
you know Roy shank is kind of painted a
little bit you think he was like this
sort of obviously years a sort of
sociopaths Psychopaths but he's quite
reasonable we've done really you can
tell they were like acquaintances and
you know they have quite a relationship
now the next two pages for me first
we're going to talk about is the color
scheme I love the way this looks I think
it's absolutely colored brilliant that
kind of low dusk yeah well there's no
like real flesh tones in it it's all
sort of reds oranges and I even the
people in the bottom panel on page 14
they're all in red or orange and there's
just sort of a real dark dingy Ness to
it yeah yeah it's but I mean odd Roenick
leads
hairy's so the bottom grill and again
when you get the external of the bar you
see that another newspaper Congress
approves lunar silos which you know that
is just obviously we if you're reading
for the first time you don't know about
document ham whatever and it's that's
another kind of point out sort of this
world but this scene is absolutely
brutal I especially love the way Harry's
face changes when he's like oh god
please don't kill anybody like you can
stand up the fear and just like the
Rorschach reflection in the mirror and
you can see also the Rorschach ink has
changed in the mirror from what it was
when he said on fine Harry how are your
self so it's kind of it looks like
you've got to think if you're facing
washing not only is it terrifying but
it's terrifying that this thing but more
thing yeah and I love like the dark
humor to it exactly the comedian is
laughing but he's doing horrific deeds
which is sort of you can sort of sum up
like you're almost aligned yourself with
the comedian in that way that you can do
these horrific things going on but you
sort of chuckle into yourself and just
the way that is friend gets up and
leaves and Rossa walks over and the way
breaks his fingers and it's just
horrific rather than show us some dark
comedy to it which it is like it's the
perfect way to say goodbye to the
comedian the world's like this where
he's been a summation of everything
wrong in it and the fact that he's able
to laugh at it and was always one of his
most terrifying aspects and the fact
that the readers now doing the same
thing and another sort of poetry - we're
almost mm-hmm definitely yeah you sort
of became you understand his view of the
world definitely foreign carrying this
and this whole bar scene we get one of
several references throughout the entire
book of royal acts
Rorschach's smell you know again this is
some of it takes care of his diet this
is someone that uses the Odra and you
know who keeps cleaning in any sort of
way and we have this sort of ignorant
guy that you've got to think this guy
must be aware of war shagging somebody
pushing his luck saying you know such an
abrasive comment out loud and
when Rorschach's breaking his fingers
which is a very what you never see he
even Batman probably wouldn't like it
recognized finger like in a bar is
absolutely it's horrendous
yeah and the fact that he's able to just
walk into a bar and do it as well yeah
everyone's scared of him they know he's
an absolute psychopath and he's using
his reputation to strike fear not to
help people which is you know Superman
would never just walk in somewhere and
start slapping someone's finger the
answers that you wanted was people
looked on and it's a very sort of
dictator and almost bullying way to get
information yeah really just hit the
scary oh I was able to do this and no
one will stop them at all no and just
just when he's talking to the crowd is
like I've just broke this gentleman's
little finger who killed Edward break
Edward break and his index finger
who killed Edward Blake like it's just
yeah let the thing he's not changing his
tact it's not like or broken one finger
I haven't got what one is I'm gonna go
through the whole hand and you know you
can eventually he's like holding this
guy off what the guy's collapsed on the
floor in idea and he's still holding his
hand he's just crazy and another thing
like not only the breaking out
compassionate all zero
yeah you know I mean absolute zero and
again in superior comics you know you
get like the bad guys gain and you
assume they're bad guys but you assume
all they're just they're just evil but
you know here Rorschach says I leave the
human cockroaches to discuss their
heroin and child pornography yeah it's
just like he clearly has no remorse of
what he's just done and in his mind I
can imagine him thing and they got off
easy
Ricky I didn't really they're lucky I'm
investigating this comedian case
otherwise I would have spent a lot more
time there like Harry's about the bar
owner he obviously knows Rorschach's
been in there before
and and maybe has killed people in there
and you know you just don't know this
Azuri like in Venus to bleakness through
it yeah yeah yeah completely and and you
know again juxtaposition is a huge thing
in this book and going from this kind of
destitute squalor
- Adrienne you know Adrienne voyage
Amanda Amanda and again when I was
saying that thing about perspective the
first thing we see is his giant Tower
and you know he is this kind of Mark
Zuckerberg Bill Gates Alexander the
Great type figure you know fascinating
fascinating character and you know I
love the idea as well that we you know
we see the tower and then we see what
Rorschach inside the tower and later we
learned that of course he grappled in
and sort of came in and I don't about
you but energy Mendes I see kind of a
critique of sort of like comic culture
at that time with the toy lines and the
sort of the capitalist of merchandise
yeah yeah yeah exactly you sort of taken
these ideologies and turn them into
commodities really and he doesn't stand
for any of them at all anymore and but
the world kind of wants to you view him
as this great superhero when in all
honestly like if when they recount the
stories of me you didn't really do much
he sort of took his skill and and used
it to make money and he wasn't he wasn't
it was noble what you did he didn't want
to help people and he just wanted to to
sort of control the world and yeah sorry
no no I just I mean you say you didn't
to help people which I do agree
he is quite narcissistic in that sense
but you see and I only knows it's like
just recently you see in the bottom left
of page 17 the Aussie man dies you can't
really really bridge the Indian famine
relief which is kind of a meeting I
believe that's where dr. Manhattan and
Hollis Mason me a convoy have dominated
is referenced in a few things as well so
it does have that kind of philanthropist
you know thing but obviously it's kind
of with different intentions here but I
love seeing them interact and I love
also that second panel where it's white
outside and it's got that giant floor
and it's just kind of the sense of scale
of kind of you know of what he has
achieved what he has sort of thing and
you know obviously Rorschach is there to
kind of warn him about what's going on
stuff of that and I love how he's called
like you know the smartest man in the
world and this sort of stuff and we
don't really
not really given any clue to what he is
even with no you get a bit more but with
Ozymandias you just know that he's his
millionaire and you know a lot and it's
just what we see of him on the final
thing we see for of him we see him
standing up and then free of him in toy
form yeah yeah it sort of it's very
narcissistic and that carried it forward
and he always thinks he's in the right
and and he sort of will go to the ends
of the earth and to almost change the
world so it fits to what he thinks it
should be mmm-hmm and he kind of wear it
whereas the Keene act forced Android
burg to stop being a superhero he says
here nobody retired me I chose to quit
adventuring and go public two years
before the police strike made the Keene
act necessary so he has that foresight
in a certain sense to kind of anticipate
the worlds changes and yet you know kind
of react to them knowingly and again
with the sense of juxtaposition moving
from sequence the sequence we see on his
desk the newspaper and it says Geneva
talks us I think it's like refers to
discuss refuses to discuss dr. Manhattan
and you can see it up to my hand on
thing and of course we get to dr.
Manhattan now who either about yourself
for me he's probably the most
fascinating character in Watchmen Oh
100% just for the way that you've used
time yeah like that I've always sort of
thought that is how time is and that
humans just see it and linear because
that's just the way our mind is used to
dealing with things and if everything
was simultaneously sorry some atonia see
happening at once then we would just all
go mad and so it's really interesting to
see this character sort of embody
everything that I've thought about about
time and how space and gravity and
everything works yeah yeah I mean
obviously Watchmen we're going to be
doing you know twelve different episodes
but it kind of needs to be viewed as a
whole I have to say though I think the
fourth issue which is dr. Manhattan's
origin is probably my favorite I think I
got absolutely fascinated yeah I think I
think it's a masterpiece like I read
the other day lures me I think it's
probably one of the better sequences in
the film as well I think I did that
quite well
older old Zack but we get here to the
Rockefeller military research center you
see sort of a superhero Superman logo
kind of on the board yeah did just
notice that as well I've never looked as
in-depth as going panel by panel in this
but you can really there are little
subtle things that oh yes he glanced
over and dr. manhattan's sort of is to
me what Superman would be like if he
existed in the real world and you
wouldn't be this guy who's like saving
cats up trees he would just sort of be
nonchalant he'd probably view himself
above everyone and whilst he might want
to help he would never see himself as an
equal to them and if you had this
unlimited power I mean how could you see
yourself accorded to people who were
just restrained by age and time and just
their own emotions whereas dr. Manhattan
is just completely in control of himself
all the time and we get kind of insight
into war shackle a lot always on this
page page 19 not only you know he can
break into a military research center
which you know you see there are armed
guards and stuff so he's quite good at
what he does he is quite sleuthy but I
love the background that we get here
especially into the Minutemen as well
and we sort of you know he says why are
so few of us left active healthy and
without personality disorders obviously
it's somewhat ironic that he's saying
that you know in a great sort of things
but you know he said the first Nite Owl
runs an auto repair shop as we met the
first Silk Spectre is a bloated aging
[ __ ] captain metropolis is decapitated
car crash mothman's in an asylum
silhouette retiring disgrace murdered
six weeks later by my knee and my
adversary which I love by the way that's
such a cool that's such a cool idea like
we're a superior retires and then maybe
someone you know like having comics like
minor villains like tracks them down and
kills them we just killed it's probably
what would happen like if they were real
like why wouldn't they you know
they get about so good no no they get
the gab Arkham Asylum or whatever and
you know why wouldn't they just try and
slip Batman throat like they wouldn't
kind of try and fight him again on his
terms they we exactly
they were just track him down yeah walk
up behind them in a queue and just shoot
them in the back they're just uh yeah
and um I love as well you know obviously
Dave Gibbons a detail when when he says
the comedian's dead and Rorschach opens
the door from your side and you see the
lettering reflected on the floor and
it's just really nice just just river
another thing is when you talked about
Adrian right says possibly homosexual
yeah must remember to investigate
further like what yeah but it was it
kind of shows how homophobic he is
really intense and I mean gay gay people
win acknowledged that openly by like
them the mainstream at this time and to
have it in a comic you would never ever
before this have any character
acknowledged as gay like Batman and
Robin used to have sleepovers and stuff
and they wouldn't a little bit no one
would ever think all they might be gay
right and she just openly say it here is
possibly homosexual and must investigate
further
it's a that real next step towards
deconstructionism that yeah oh yeah yeah
completely completely and you know it's
kind of surprising I also think like
it's a bit surprising that you can just
kind of get into this and open the door
and and you know man hands there but we
love that we've kind of had these muted
tones it's raining outside
and then we get into the blue and I
guess you could argue Rorschach has his
own speech bubbles that are ragged but
really the only character that has
unique speech balls is dr. Manhattan
with the blue it's so different from
everyone else and and the fact he knows
Rorschach has sneaking in like he's
aware of everything at once
and he's just clearly not bothered
because he knows that there's nothing on
the planet that can do any harm to him
he just saw exists through like carefree
and because he's so carefree stop caring
and that just saw so that sort of ties
into another thing that is how I think
Superman would act if you were to exist
you would because no one could harm him
he would stop caring about everything
yeah yeah yeah complete I think that's
kind of the beauty of Superman isn't it
that he's an alien life-form but he has
like human parents and he was raised so
he kind of has that where and I guess
you could argue dr. Manhattan he was
human and we learned that dr.
Manhattan's been this way for like 20
years or so or something like that so
it's you know it's been quite a while
for his humanity to detach but you know
him that's what I love the way we meet
him as a giant man you know with light
at his fingers kind of just engaging
with this huge machinery it is
fascinating and then you know him saying
a live body and a dead body contain the
same number of particles structurally
there's no discernible difference yeah
just show doesn't care just doesn't care
about human life not much of a superhero
he's not going to make any real effort
to try and save anyone do you dispute as
all as you know we're dead anyway
basically so what's the point yeah yeah
completely just that equanimity is just
and what like reading this it really
great it's quite affecting like
philosophically like what he's exploring
here these kind of dual realities and
you know incredibly well done and
obviously we have Laurie here as well
who you might you know be forgiven to
think he's just kind of you know a
distraction for him really doesn't have
that much import on the plot but she
talks about her mother here you know we
mentioned for comedian trying to rape
her mother which is just for can't
believe it and I love as well the
sequence where dr. on hat and says the
kind of life and death thing and then
you watch him in the background walk
over and like raise this giant machine
yes yeah it's also a little unsure that
means I know I keep saying nonchalant
you know yeah but no real official word
of the podcast yeah and but he just
keeps walking over picks it up and just
carries on doing what he's doing he's
not you know Rorschach being a good guy
in this issue because you go around at
all of his former partners and warning
them that there's a there's a murderer
out there somewhere and he's hunting for
like superheroes and in the fact that
dr. Manhattan just oh yeah shut up and
getting on with the rest of this is more
important just shows how much
cares about what Rorschach has to say
yeah the conversation sort of gets
derailed by Laurie talking about rape
and even then
Rorschach's just like I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna like judge people follow moral
at moral lapses yeah unless cries and
she says moral lapses but there's kind
of a commentary on dr. Manhattan here
isn't her it's like he's going for a
moral lapse like you know that is kind
of like you can almost argue that I'm
not you know no i defending what the
comedian did but like it was a
passionate thing you know but he's a
evil bastard so of course it's probably
calculated but you know back to my hand
it's almost worse because he's kind of
completely passive there and you've got
to think as well I kind of wonder when I
read this I'm like for the sake of the
book he needs to warn dr. Han because we
need to meet dr. Mann - great scene but
why did he need to ward off a man really
dr. manhattan's indestructible no I'm
going to kill him yeah I don't know if
he a Rorschach deep down trying to get
the old band back together
yeah he sort of knows something to come
in and you just wants to make everyone
aware of it to see if they're going to
side with them and rise up against their
book it's just every door gets slammed
in his face basically yeah yeah yeah no
one says thank you no one kind of I
guess it gets kind of basically my
obviously eats the sugar as well here
that he took earlier from Dan which is
quite quite nice to see kind of almost
all but over to the dr. Manhattan sense
like you know I'm picking up the sugar -
that I will eat in 40 minutes and you
know it sort of seemed kind of going
back and forth there and then on the
next page there's some nice stuff it
because I love how Rorschach is the
perspective of him between dr.
Manhattan's legs yeah yeah kind of tiny
there and you see that what a dr.
Manhattan still kind of cares you know
he's not completely dead he says you
seem to be upsetting Laurie he wants him
to go you ignore the conflict yeah but
you just I think that's just because
it's you know he's trying to concentrate
on this thing and two people are
argument in person tonight doesn't care
oh yeah it's just though right you've
gone and there's nothing that Rorschach
can do to stop it I mean tries to
protest it and I'm not leaving before
Pat might say well
or even finishes sentences I hope the
buildin mmm yeah and it always reminds
me of the final issue when spoilers
dr. Manhattan kills Rorschach it's kind
of similar isn't it he just kind of
looks at him and he just integrates but
in this case he relocates and you learn
I mean okay we've seen dr. Manhattan as
a giant doing all this computer stuff
moving but here you see wow you can just
transport people just in a second to
outside yeah I mean use his power is
endless you can do anything you want you
can see that you can put his hand
through solid object you you can make
things levitate you can transport people
you can lift things above his head he
can change his mass and you can shrink
down the size of an atom or you can
expand beyond you know to to the height
of a giant you can do whatever he wants
and it is God basically in this world
but no one really acknowledges them as
that apart from you know the odd news
reporter again it's just such an
interesting character I mean the
normality of everything else and then he
sort of is the only thing that you sort
of would see in a comic book movie at in
a comic book you know he is the Superman
and and to discover that if the Superman
did exist in a world not too dissimilar
from ours he'd be like a [ __ ]
basically yes quite shocking yeah yeah
Couvillion again I just love the
dialogue between them she she mentions
Dan and them going out and you get the
sense wait after you've read it a bit
you realize that dr. Matt and sees
everything at once a doctor and knows
what's going to happen he knows that
they're mean I was gonna lead to
landfill even Gary's gonna you know lead
to whatever sort of thing and you know
she says I'll call him up ask him out to
dinner if you don't mind that of course
not I'll join you but I think I'm close
to locating a gluey no which would
completely validate supersymmetrical
theory it was included in the best area
and it is likewise you know just kind of
so self-absorbed there and it's great to
see him it kind of looks like he's
smiling when she's calling Dan but maybe
he's happy for her because she knows
she'll be happy in some way finally I
don't know yeah
because obviously they're not on the
same level like I think you know I don't
want to slug the last off
Lori's clearly just went out with dr.
Manhattan for a status symbol yeah and
dr. Manhattan knows deep down you know
he's not emotionally available to anyone
and so it's probably better that she ate
ends up with someone like Dan I mean
he's going to have to watch if dr.
Manhattan stays with or he's going to
have to watch her grow old and then it
would probably be a repeat of what
happens later in the book Gracie dr.
Manhattan's previous girlfriend ma'am
and he just becomes disinterested in her
because she's aging and he's just
staying still and so I think deep down
he is happy because he knows what's
going to happen to his ex-girlfriend and
so he sort of one doesn't want that life
for Laurie yeah yeah no and I mean
another mind it's obviously been poor
over these touches but it's called as
Laurie's ringing Dan and and dr.
Manhattan's work in his machine you see
the puddle that Rorschach left behind as
you like disappeared and you know the
rain from outside and stuff of that and
then we get to the the next page page 24
when Rorschach is kind of returning home
we get his journal again he looks in the
window the kind of symbol of the two
people becoming one is not only the kind
of the ink blot but also his mother and
her clients that we see and you know
it's a kind of common recurring theme
here we all yes was to see that picture
of Nixon with four more years because
obviously Nixon's have like three terms
now it is kind of this this alternative
history old all these little things here
and I love um in the second and that the
following page a 25th page where we
learn about Laurie kind of just being
there to almost keep tabs on dr.
Manhattan you know to keep them happy
but after watching that scene you're
like well you clearly like you don't
give him anything yeah she like offers
nothing to just being put in there
because the government thinks are this
man needs a good woman alone and make
sure he's doing all right and it's just
it just sums up the government they
think they're right all the time and
really they have no
idea of what's going on like getting on
later into the book when dr. Manhattan
goes AWOL they the government have got
absolutely no idea and it because you
just cannot on any level relate to this
superpower being and by chance is
American yeah and they're they think
they've got them under control and the
fact is that don't at all no no not at
all and and this is kind of a nice kind
of building out the the story here
between the both Laurie says looking
back you know I spent eight years in
semi-retirement preceded by ten years
running around a stupid costume because
my stupid mother wanted to will sort of
you know explore that theme of
inheritance officers to like night owls
there's kind of you know the Silk
Spectre and Miss Jupiter and sort of
that they have their kind of reflections
here and then it's interesting that Dan
has the smiling badge on him still like
yeah but I wonder why keeping that
around I think you just sort of want an
attachment to the life that used to have
and this is the only thing that's really
came along recently that's like relevant
that makes him relevant again in it it's
almost like it a totem of the the old
world that he used to live in him and
it's it now something new and you just
wants to keep ahold of it because it
reminds them of exactly what that you
know that is still a need out there for
these heroes and we return to that you
know that classic kind of paneling
structure here them reminiscing on the
final page about captain carnage which
it is pretty funny actually like the
idea not be quite dark read that this
guy was a villain T sexually get off on
it it is quite an odd thing yeah he
would never hope of before this a super
villain and the only motive is that they
sexually like yeah yeah yeah I mean it's
a great idea it's a great twist on the
idea but it's just kind of and then I
love them talks about you know whatever
happened to him he pulled it on
Rorschach and Rorschach dropped it down
an elevator shaft
yeah just so he doesn't know Rorschach
doesn't understand this world that you
inhabit he just thinks everything is
from like a comic book and that there's
bad guys and there's good
if you see a bad guy there's no point
understanding exactly what's driven him
to be the way that years it's literally
just like oh well you're a bad guy so
I'm going to have to kill you
there's no compassion there or there's
no sort of trying to figure out exactly
what made and ye is it's just you're a
villain hero I'm gonna murder you
yeah yeah is black and white definitely
as it is way and I've literally just
realized this death but I'm sure it's
gonna happen throughout the show when we
know these things never notice poor but
the first page of this issue in the
final pages issue are kind of the same
where yeah they both open on that smiley
face and then pull out I never realized
yeah yeah yeah that's crazy yeah isn't
that crazy that's so clever and like
again you can sort of see this morning
basically pull out but you know whereas
now we pulled out on a dead body we're
pulling out and kind of like hope I
guess in a certain sense with with Dan
and Laurie yeah you know we again you
know the canal was really hoping there
that the opening words would be the
comedian is dead but they're not
unfortunately if you're a to Shanghai
don't open then the comedian is dead and
closed I would have been over the moon
but it didn't know but I mean regatta is
genius the night I'm just scouring that
final panel as well but you can see on
the rooftop they came out these stairs
and as that are on top of the roof and
the earth see there at Rafael's and I
just I mean Dave Gibbons is a genius
like like seriously like the level of
defunding is absolutely incredible and
then we get you know all these all these
issues end of a quote and one of the
name of the issue is derived from the
concert the name of the issue is at
midnight all the agents and then this is
a Bob Dylan quote at midnight all the
agents of superhuman crew go out and
round up everyone and knows more than
they do which is just so foreboding for
the whole thing yeah under a percent I
mean tire Ock summed up there basically
and just so like foreshadowing yeah yeah
once the Doomsday Clock gets to midnight
all the agents in the CEO who human crew
go out and round up everyone who knows
more than they do which you know
spoilers Ozymandias sort of
does that he runs of everyone and yeah
yeah it's just crazy
yeah yeah yeah and I mean that is the at
the end of the issue them just
reflecting on the convenience there but
of course one of the great things about
watching one of the unique things about
Watchmen is at the end of each issue
that's kind of you know there's some
written text which not only shows you
how incredible of a writer Alan Moore is
that you can inhabit all these different
voices and he's just as good at writing
straight fiction you know what I mean
right a traveling comic books is is pen
never use a power up term is is
phenomenal yeah just just a quick thing
before we get into this excerpt from
under the hood this is again from
Wikipedia the end of each issue of
Watchmen with the exception of issue 12
contains supplementary prose pieces
written by more among the contents of
fictional book chapters letters reports
and articles written by various Watchmen
characters DC had trouble selling ad
space and issues of Watchmen which left
an extra eight to nine pages per issue
DC plan to insert house ads and a longer
letters column to fill the space but
editor Len Wein felt this would be
unfair to anyone who wrote in during the
last four issues of series he decided to
use the extra pages to fill out the
series backstory Moore said quote but it
only got around to issue three or four
and so on we thought that the book look
nice about a letters page it looked less
like a comic book so we stuck with it
and I don't know about you death that I
love the supplementary pieces at the end
I think they add so much to the universe
100% my chisel basically gives such a
backstory to everything and the flesh is
out the characters in ways that you
would never think like reading a
superheroes or a biography is great like
we're never going to have that in our on
like universe so it's incredible to read
it here in this this book and it
probably is the exact form that the
autobiography would take yeah I mean I
feel somewhat mine like that and mash up
after in that way really right in their
personality and then their style it's
just outstanding it really really is
outstanding because we meet Holly's
briefly and we see his book on his shelf
and if this does feel like Collison
it is so true isn't it there are so many
things ways like if superheroes are real
this would happen this would happen they
would definitely write autobiographies
yes yes definitely and they would be
huge sellers like you know these year
what in our culture not supers but you
know footballers giant figures they all
write their autobiographies you know
sportsmen celebrities so put on Prime
Minister's etc so it makes sense and you
know I love this I just I just love the
idea that we write songs when we learn
about it and kind of like the first the
first kind of section which focuses on
his days in the garage and you know
movin and being cheated on by his wife
or him sort of crying it's very it's
like it's like the badge isn't it it's
kind of like the comic and the horrific
yeah exactly
really summarized with the comedian I
mean there's so much tragedy going on in
the Aaron or everyone's just standing
back and laughing at it and hits a
really sad story and it's a about a guy
who is his best friend that they
personally trusts cheats on his wife and
another person II trust and with them
gone he realizes that he has nothing and
but he sort of joins in the joke just to
save face and then later that might kill
themselves and to and it's just it's
really heartbreaking but you can kind of
see that why this would happen in this
world like in any normal circumstances
no one would stand about and laugh at
someone who's just been cheated on and
by their wife in their best friend and
this really just to meet stands out as
this world is very twisted and you know
it's go away Stover by humor because
people are willing like if people stop
laughing then they're going to come to
the horrifying realization of this is
how the world works
hmm and I love the section where yeah he
speaks about him sort of accepting the
affair and then quote that no he sent
everyone home early then running a tube
from the exhaust of one of the shops
more operational vehicles in through the
car window he started at the engine and
drifted off into a final bit of sleep
amongst the carbon dioxide fumes and
then the most tragic thing is his
brother took over the business and
eventually reemployed Fred ma because
she was really likable yeah yeah it is
just like I mean awful like you know the
the reason he commits suicide is now
working there again and that's kind of
the intro and Hollis who's a very sort
of homey guy you know he sort of
as he's been told that the way you know
you get someone simply by telling them
saddest things I think though the the
following idea of him sort of probing
his own personality why became the night
owl and also the appearance of hooded
justice as a kind of influence getting
to it's so well done yeah it's
absolutely brilliant and the fact that
they mentioned Superman in comics yeah
sure when it just you can see how a
policeman would want that escalate into
you know stepping outside of and going
above and beyond what the law can do in
order to stop these criminals and it's
sort of quite an inspiring story and it
really does make feel like I'm surprised
more people don't sort of take up this
inspiration and become vigilant its
themselves hmm yeah and kind of be when
he's recounting hoodie justice kind of
what went down here saying young man the
gang started to beat and physically
bruised a young man more frankly
indecently assaulted girlfriend at this
point the crime is interrupted by figure
who dropped into the alley from above
with something over his face and
receiving consarn the attackers and
beating them with such severity that all
three required hospital treatment and
the one subsequently thought the use of
both legs as a revolts spinal injury so
he is like the savageness of these
characters he doesn't pull any punches
no definitely not also sort of makes you
question their morality like the heroes
and was it hood justice who got
mentioned that he eventually went insane
I know that was the Mothman Rayo Kato
would think was hooded just as killed
and in a turnstile Doris and and that
was actually dollar bill right how did
you lose the one they think might be gay
and I think he died in a Korra number
how he died apparently and we're going
to get interested in a future episode
because Alan Moore Apple watchman wrote
part of the Watchmen role-playing game
which has like an and stuff and
apparently in that comedian killed
hooded justice replies not mentioned in
the book nobody justices kind of he was
basically the first one he was the first
ones put on the mask and kind of kicked
off this whole con and movement with
night Alamos Jupiter and stuff like that
but and and he's obviously the guy that
sort of stopped
comedian from raping miss Jupiter as
well yeah which you know Robbie where
they come in didn't kill them yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah probably just revenge
for that sort of that but I mean all in
all an incredible first issue yeah
alright a bits masterpiece yeah what
like looking in depth as it is I mean
it's just absolutely there's so much
effort that's been put into it you never
really see this in comics and any more
all really very rare that you pick up
the first issue of something and it's
this heavy with depth and little minor
details that eventually have massive
payoffs it's incredible I think how
symbolic some of the panels are and just
so well done and it's just a delight to
read hmm no it really it really really
is and you know this is going to be a
great theory I can already tell you're
going to be great obviously if you're
listening to this please subscribe this
is on desk channel subscribe to the
channel there's lots more comic book
stuff on there you know comment below
share all the good stuff there isn't you
know we've been looking there isn't
really any other watching stuff out
there so you can count on us and we'll
be back soon to dig into issue to absent
friends which covers like you know the
funeral of the comedian has loads of
great Minute Men flashbacks and I know
Moloch as well and all that sort of we
learn more about you know what comedian
discovered and all that stuff but death
this is this has been a joy man yeah
great first episode great first issue
all round brilliant yet really happy
with how that went so make sure you like
comment share subscribe do what I'm
telling you to do now or I'll find you
and I'll push you out the window
so yeah yeah it would be a totally doing
this every month and so keep an eye out
for issue two it's a good night from me
alright yet yeah I mean who watches the
Watchmen that's what I'm going to ask at
the end and hopefully you know you watch
this I can't think of anything way to
end on so I'll just reimburse eyes read
if you to the in-depth building up to
this audience and you know we will be
there with you going through I mean we
could have spent another hour on this
issue really you know
so so much there's lots of great web
pages out there that really break it
down and you know there's tons of stuff
we missed but it's been great going
through this and yeah it cheers again
guys that's we're listening
[Music]